à
on s'arrête on se pose et on regarde
dans quel état on se trouve
[Musique]
regarde comment respire dans quel état
et notre corps dans quel état sont nos
pensées et nos émotions qu'ils sont les
impulsions qui siège en nous et faire ça
nous permet de mieux comprendre au lieu
d'être sans arrêt dans les actions d'
aveux dans des distractions
on s'arrête et on observe ce que nous
sommes en train de vivre
[Musique]
c'est le lien le lien social de
davantage écouter les autres davantage
leurs données de pratiquer davantage
l'altruisme d'être vraiment avec pas
être à côté d'eux tous en train de
regarder son écran ou ou en train de
faire des choses qui semblent nous
réunir mais qui en fait ne correspondent
pas une vraie communication mais
vraiment régulièrement prendre le temps
d'échanger de dialoguer et d'écouter de
comprendre sans but particulier
[Musique]
le fait de régulièrement prendre du
temps pour être en contact avec des
espaces naturels nature à la campagne à
la montagne à la mer aucune importance
ou même dans des grands parcs publics et
prendre des bains nature comme on prend
des bains de soleil ou des bains de mer
sert s'immerger sans autre attente que
qu'être juste là que recharger ses
batteries
c'est quelque chose qui nous reconnecte
à l'essentiel à notre nature d'être
vivant et qui accroît notre apaisement
et notre discernement qui sont deux
ingrédients très important pour la
liberté intérieure ne peut pas être
intérieurement libre dans le stress dans
l' angoisse et dans l'aveuglément ça ne
marche pas
[Musique]
ce qui compte pour moi dans ma vie
qu'est ce que je veux faire de ma vie
finalement qu'est-ce que je voudrais
qu'on puisse inscrire sur ma pierre
tombale en forme d'épitaphe une fois que
je ne serai plus là et souvent on perd
de vue évidemment ces valeurs parce
qu'on est aspiré une fois de plus par
les obligations trivial de la vie
quotidienne et s'arrêter pour voir ce
qui compte pour nous prendre soin des
autres réalisé accomplir sa fibre ses
prédispositions artistique mené à bien
grands projets réunir certaines
personnes pour atteindre d'elle un
objectif qui nous paraît important
toutes ces valeurs d'humanité de partage
de convivialité chacun de nous les
portes et souvent malheureusement mais
les négligent et oublient de s'en
occuper en tout cas s'en occupe beaucoup
moins qu'il ne s'occupe de son travail
de son compte en banque de la réparation
de sa voiture ouvre sa chasse d'eau